hey everybody Mr Kobe here I'm going to
do a
demonstration of our dialysis lab
activity and this right here is dialysis
tube oops it kind of just looks like a
piece of flat plastic it doesn't really
look like a tube but what I've already
done is I soaked another piece in water
and uh just to show you if I rub my
fingers uh it actually is a tube you can
rub your finger you know you rub your
fingers while it's soaked in water I
tied a knot in the bottom you can see I
tied a knot in the bottom and I just
added some water here and you can see
yeah it's inflated uh it it really is a
tube so even though it looked like just
a piece of flat plastic it really is a
tube now dialysis membrane is kind of
interesting because the membrane is also
semi-permeable you can't see them
they're way too small but there's little
tiny pores little tiny holes pores in
the membrane and because it's
semi-permeable some molecules are able
to pass in and out through the pores of
this dialysis membrane and that's going
to be the experiment that we're going to
be doing we're going to try to figure
out uh which molecules can pass through
the pores of this membrane we put it
back in the uh in in in the watery cup
over here first
so ultimately what we're going to try to
figure out is this is a bottle of
glucose can glucose pass through the
dialysis membrane this is a bottle of
starch can starch pass through the
dialysis membrane and this is a bottle
of a dropper filled with iodine can
iodine pass through the dialysis
membrane so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to pause the
video and I'm G to
fill a dialysis membrane with 5
milliliters of starch 5 milliliters of
glucose I'll be right
back okay I'm back and what I did was I
took the dialysis membrane that I showed
you earlier and I added use the
graduated cylinder I added 5 m of starch
and 5 m L of glucose so right now
there's about 10 mlit when you add it up
there's about 10 m inside of this
dialysis membrane again 5 milliliters of
starch 5 milliliters of glucose what I'm
going to do is I'm going to put this
dialysis membrane in this cup of
water and make sure that it's
submerged and you can see the other end
the open end is just dangling outside
the cup now what I'm going to do I'm
going to take my iodine here my iodine
I'm going add about 30 drops doesn't
have to be exact but I'm going to add
about 30 drops of iodine 1 2 3 4 five 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
21 22 23 2 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 hey you
know they say one for good
luck here we go one extra drop for good
luck all right now what I'm going to do
I'm going to let this cup this testing
cup here I'm going to let it sit and the
longer I can let it sit the better now
remember what we're trying to figure out
is I got these three uh molecules here
starch iodine and glucose I'm trying to
figure out which of these are able to
pass through the dialysis membrane I
know there's starch in inside the
membrane I added 5 milliliters does it
diffuse out into the cup I don't know
we'll
see you just saw me add iodine into the
cup into the watery cup but does the
iodine that is right now in the watery
cup does it diffuse into the dialysis
membrane I don't know we have to wait
and we'll see in a moment and then
glucose I added 5 milliliters of glucose
into the dialysis membrane so does
glucose diffuse outward into the cup I
don't know we have to wait and find out
so I'm going to let this sit for 20 30
minutes or so I'm going to pause the
video I'll be back in a
moment so before I go back to the
dialysis membrane I want to just draw
this on the Whiteboard this is kind of a
drawing of where we stand uh so we've
got a cup filled with iodine and water
and in the dial is membrane is 5 m of
glucose 5 m of starch the glucose and
starch are all mixed together it's not
like they're layered and sitting on top
of one another like my drawing and so
what I'm trying to figure out does
glucose come
out I don't know we'll have to see if
there's a way to test for that I have to
figure out does
starch come out of the dialysis membrane
and into the cup I don't know we'll have
to figure out a way to test and I
I know there's iodine in the water does
Iodine go into the dialysis membrane U
again I'm not going to give the answer
away there has to be a way for us to
figure this out but these are really the
three big questions we're going to
explore okay so I want to show a couple
observations before we go back to
showing the results so first of all I
want to show you what happened when
starch and iodine mix here's a graduated
cylinder filled with starch if you
notice if I put on the black part of the
table right here see starch is kind of a
cloudy milky white color and I'm going
to leave it there on the black part of
the table so we can see better and iine
you I'm sure you know has like an orange
bronze color but when I add some
iodine into the starch let's see what
happens uh one two let's add three drops
and notice if I kind of hold it up to
the camera here shake it up a little bit
you can see like a blackish color and
it's actually a blackish and a little
bit of a purple tint to it of forms if I
again Shake It Up and swirl it up a
little bit maybe if I put it against
yeah it almost looks black on my camera
but it's a a blackish purplish color
begins to form so when starch and iodine
mix that's what you might see when
starch and iodine mix you see like this
blackish and I don't know if you can
tell if it shows well in the camera I
don't think it does but it Al almost has
like a purplish color so that's one
observation right there starch and
iodine make that color when they mix now
if I move over
here I have two beakers one of them is a
glucose Solution on the left and one of
them is just distilled water and what
I'm going to do I'm going to use these
testing pads right here these testing
strips now this is a glucose test strip
and you can see the tip of the pad has a
blue colored pad on it and so if I dip
this into the solutions what this will
do it will react if there's glucose
present so first of all I'm going to dip
it in the one of distilled water because
this is distilled water there should not
be any glucose in here swirl it back and
forth there we go and I'm just going to
set it right there for now and then I'm
going to take another one here's another
one a fresh one and I'm going to swirl
this one into a mixture that has glucose
I know there's glucose in here I made it
up earlier so it's a mixture with
glucose take it out and again let it sit
and if I look at the colors you can
already see that there's a color change
the one on the left which I know there
was glucose in the solution T turn
colors and the one on the right didn't
and here's a fresh one so this one that
I'm shaking right now is fresh it's
never been used
uh I don't know how well the color is
out it doesn't look like the color short
very well there we go um you can see
there that this one on the right is
fresh it's never been used and it looks
just like the one on the left which has
been used that tells me there's no
glucose in this and that's fine there's
not supposed to be this is distilled
water and now if I take the fresh one
that's never been used here it is on the
right never been used compare it to the
one on the left you can see there's a
clear color ch change there's a clear
obvious difference color change well
that's because I dipped it in glucose
and I knew there was glucose now the pad
might not always turn brown if I hold up
this right here you can see um if
there's no glucose from on the left the
pad's going to be blue and you can see
if there's a little bit of glucose it's
that greenish color a medium amount of
glucose is like that olive color and if
there's a lot of glucose it's the brown
color so it might not turn brown
uh but if the pad even turns a green
color that means there's glucose present
if it turns an olive color that means
there's glucose present okay I'm going
pause and we're going to go back to our
experiment okay so here are the results
I actually got a little busy and it's
kind of just been sitting here longer
than I had actually thought which is not
a bad thing it's actually a good thing
the longer it sits the more Vivid the
results um I I intended to let it sit
for about 20 minutes but it's actually
been a little over an hour so uh first
thing I want to do I want to hold up the
dialysis bag you can see hey there's
there's a there's something inside that
wasn't there before you can see that
there's a dark purplish color inside of
the dialysis bag the dialysis membr that
that color wasn't there
before um but it is it's there now so my
hope is based on what we've seen
throughout this video you can explain
why is that dark purplish color there it
wasn't there
before now I'm going to leave the
dialysis bag just right here and I'll
clean up the mess afterwards um but if I
look in the testing cup the testing cup
still has that same orangish bronze
color you know from the iodine I don't
see anything different there's no spots
there's nothing built up at the bottom
there's no colored change so the iodine
water mixture that's in the cup looks
normal it's just that same orange bronze
color well that's an observation right
there I hope you know what that might
imply and the last thing I want to do I
have two of those glucose testing strips
I'm only going to use one I'll use this
one right here and I'm just going to
swirl it back and
forth give it a second tap it dry and
the one on the left I just used us the
one in on the right right here that I'm
shaking in front of the camera I've
never used so there's the one on the
left that's been used now here comes a
fresh one that I've never used
before and I hope it shows up nicely on
the camera I think it does um I can see
again um from just looking around the
camera that the one on the left is more
of a greenish color than what it started
as the one on the right is the one on
the right right here is fresh it's never
been used it has that same blue color as
before but the colors don't look too
good right now but the one on the left
come on iPhone you can do it there it
goes I think that looks better the one
on the left is clearly a changed colors
that tells me something when I swirled
this glucose testing strip in the iodine
water it turned colors that should tell
me something okay so based on the
observations I just explained and if you
have to rewind the video and watch it
again you should be able to answer all
the questions in your lab handout that
you have right here all right thanks for
watching hope that helped bye